je m'appelle l'ariane felder j'ai 40 ans
je suis juge d'instruction célibataire
et sans enfant son blog
non je suis une femme intelligente donc
c'est pas possible
la fécondation a eu lieu à environ six
mois
quartier du palais de justice le soir du
31 décembre et 10 la tête elles tiennent
bon
on valide donc pas les fausses notes
qu'amiens ça suffit on arrête ça j'ai
une bonne nouvelle on à fond une mère
multiples et déjà fiché
accusé d'une agression assez intéressant
tenez vous bien il m'a bouffé les lieux
jour il pas perdu ma peur compétition
mais non je mange pas les yeux des gens
nient pas pleuvoir en a si bien compris
est une très bonne juge
ça m'intéressait leur histoire
d'agression et de bouffe est ce que j'y
suis pour rien c'est un accident il ça
fait trois semaines qu'elle fait pipi
c'est un énorme chèque qui faisait noir
corrige glisse dans son pipi et
tranchant ils partent en l'air
c'est quelqu'un qui pourrait la lumière
la loupe à gagner avec les experts un
même très bête
le tribunal vous qu'on donne à
l'exclusion tout là le père
c'est pour ça au père qu'il est tard et
débile si vous entendez exécution
immédiate
et d'agde est top
tu perds tu pleures mais fera pas
bouffer voilà